وهذه اذن صور مباشره مشاهدينا لوصول
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان لاحد لجان
الاقتراع في اسطنبول كما نشاهد امامنا اذا
وصل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الى
احدى مراكز الاقتراع ايضا الموجوده في
اسطنبول ياتي هذا بعد ان وصل كمال كالجدار
اوغلو الى مركز
الى مركز الانتخابي واحد الرجال للادلاء
بصوتي يصل الان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان للادلائي بصوته ايضا كذلك في هذه
الانتخابات وفي احدى مراكز الاقتراع
باسطنبول اذا وصل الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان تابعناه منذ الامس وهو طبعا قد
بدا برمجه
الانتخابي وكذلك ايضا اجتمع بمنا
وتحدث عن مستقبل تركيا يتحدث عن خطط
لمعالجه الاوضاع الاقتصاديه كذلك الحاليه
ركز ايضا على السياسه الداخليه الاقتصاديه
بشكل
خاص كذلك ايضا كان قد تحدث في تجمعاته
الانتخابيه عن السياسه الخارجيه لتركيا
الان يصل مرشح تحالف الشعب
رئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان الى احدى
مراكز الاقتراع باسطنبول ياتي هذا بعد ان
وصل كمال كلجدار اوكلو الى احدى مراكز
الاقتراع في العاصمه التركيه انقره ادلى
بصوته تحدث ايضا بعد ذلك بانه اشتاق الى
الديمقراطيه والى ربيع الحريات في تركيا
يصل الان الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
مرشح تحالف الشعب للادلاء بصوته في احدى
مراكز الاقتراع باسطنبول وكما نشاهد ياخذ
بعض ربما الصور امامنا في هذا المركز مركز
الاقتراعي يتحدث كذلك مع الموجودين في هذا
المركز انتخابات اذا تركيا توصف بانها
الانتخابات ربما الاقوى الاشد في التنافس
في تركيا منذ عقود وبانها تاتي في توقيت
صعب مهم وحساس دقيق للغايه ايضا على
المستوى السياسي على المستوى الاقتصادي
ايضا كذلك وحتى على المستوى الاجتماعي
داخل تركيا برفقته طبعا
زوجته كما نشاهد الان في هذه الصور
وابنائه ايضا وصلوا معه الى احدى مراكز
الاقتراع في اسطنبول هذه الانتخابات التي
سبقتها ربما استطلاعات للراي عبرت بشكل او
اخر كما ينقل بعض المحللين والمتابعين
ايضا
ان شعبيه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
اهتزت بعد جائحه كورونا بعد ايضا لو ضاع
الاقتصاديه المتردي وكذلك ايضا حتى ربما
بعدما حدث من زلزال تركيا وسوريا الزلزال
الذي ضرب الاجزاء الجنوبيه من تركيا
والتعامل ايضا كذلك الحكومه التركيه مع
تبعات هذا الزلزال استطلاعات الراي اشارت
ايضا الى تقدم طفيف لكمال كالجدار اوغلو
ايضا هناك بعض الاستطلاعات اظهرت بان
الرئيس التركي الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان
يتقدم في هذه
ربما الانتخابات لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات